[Music]
everybody knows Jolly Old Saint Nick
he's the bearer of good tidings and
cheer well in Austria he's not alone and
we don't mean Rudolph
these are Krampus a sort of monster that
travels with Saint Nick they scare away
bad spirits and look for naughty kids to
punish making Christmas a whole lot
scarier people in Europe have been
welcoming the Christmas season by
dressing as Krampus for hundreds of
years I am Ralph Herzog and I'm the
oldest Campos here in town altenmark
on the 5th of December we came to the
Childs in their homes and the good one
gets some sweets from the Nicolo and the
bad ones get hit with the whip from the
Krampus then we go from house to house
for five six hours and after we visited
all the children in altenmark there's a
little run with all Krampus together
[Music]
the story of Saint Nick and Krampus goes
back to 375 A.D and the costumes and
traditions haven't changed much since
the dress from the Krampus is made of
wool from the Sheep The Masks are made
of wood and so when you're walking
around to all the children to the houses
for some hours you really will get sweat
it's like a workout
it's funny to go into the houses from
the people the reaction is different
some Childs are not scared come to you
and grab to a fur and other ones
screaming and running away
the Krampus is a good reason to change
their minds from the children try to be
good for the next year
[Music]
I'm dressed as Krampus this year the
15th time I'm very lucky to go every
year I'm very proud to be a part of this
old tradition
[Music]